hello the names Roy Roy Android la more
names bond James Bond
imagine if Barnes sounded like that no
that'd suck anyway I'm gonna check out
the official trailer number two for
Spectre I'm excited to see this movie I
was looking up just before filming this
the collection of all the Bond films up
to Skyfall I've seen them like
periodically throughout the year since I
was a little kid I don't remember most
of them to be honest so I want to
revisit them and then do an awesome
[ __ ] review of Spectre before I go
into this I wanted to say I usually post
like 5 to 6 days a week from Monday
through Wednesday I might not be able to
post videos Warner Brothers is sending
me out to Fresno California they want me
to vlog and experience at the Haunted
Mansion based off the gallows and then
on Friday the Queen Mary in Long Beach
California they're sending me there to
vlog the experience there so I'm gonna
be really [ __ ] busy next week but I'll
do my best to keep the uploads
consistent anyway besides some awesome
announcements
let's get bonded up ten sequences of
action some disturbing
this organization
you know it's cold it's means Spectre
look around you James
everything you believed a woman
why did you come I came here to kill you
and I thought you came here to die well
it's all a matter of perspective
dude nipple chills right here you can't
see cuz of the bat but maybe you can
it's it's a nipple chill right there
looks [ __ ] sweet I want to watch that
again now review it and [ __ ] this
organization
you know it's cool it seems factor we're
making the round shapes
everything you believed
why did you come thank you here to kill
you
I'm scary then I thought you came here
to die told a matter of perspective
kind of have like I mean it's just a
trailer but doesn't it kind of have like
an old-school Bond vibe to it
you know Skyfall or Casino Royale they
have been you know reinventing bond but
this film kind of feels like there's
some homage it's even with Christoph
Waltz's like soot and stuff it looks
entertaining I feel like we're gonna get
more of that fun flare by that I like
higher of our dam was a great villain
and I feel like casting Christoph Waltz
my only issue with that is that we've
seen Christoph Waltz playing antagonist
several times now so I feel like it
might detract a little bit but it's
Christoph Walton he always tends to
surprise me and still make a performance
feel fresh even though it's an
antagonist again he can still provide a
different layer to it what I'm really
excited for it is the interaction
between Daniel Craig and Christoph Waltz
I feel like there's gonna be some great
acne moments in those scenes the Mexica
I think it's in Mexico the Mexico
setting looks great a mane I'd like a
martini shaken not stirred and a corona
lightening that back and forth is gonna
be the quota movie you know like when
he's like why did you come Jane why did
you come I need to grow up why you why'd
you come James and then he's like I
can't get the [ __ ] stupid come joke
out of my head back and forth of like
why did you come James I came here to
kill you
funny I thought you came here to die
well it's all a matter of perspective I
would like it if they did the delivery
more like how I just did it that would
be a much more interesting scene I
really wonder how they're gonna end the
bond story with Daniel Craig is bond
because I feel like it's a story that is
gonna conclude actually which kind of
makes me a little worried cuz bond has
been able to last all these years
because we never really got back story
it was never really that personal but
ever since Casino ray out is an actual
like storyline going on here that makes
the films connected so it takes away
some of that mystique mysteriousness a
bond I feel like it's great for now but
will it possibly put an end to the
franchise because we can't just go back
to like not exploring bond now and I
heard this is the second to last Bond
film that Daniel Craig is under contract
for so we've got
more after this I mean this one looks
great it's it's just I don't think
they've ever done that I could be
totally wrong but I don't think they
ever brought a director I know they
brought it a director back before but I
don't think they brought a director to
come back for two films in a row Sam
Mendes he [ __ ] delivers he's one of
my favorite directors out there I like
with the cinematography it you know
they're kind of like how that Dark
Knight of the Dark Knight Rises or like
a lot of nolan films kind of have like
that sepia kind of color tone to it i
see a similar color tone here but yeah
what I want out of this film I want it
to be fun I want it to be action packed
I want to see more bond gadgets like
what happened to that [ __ ] man mission
impossible feels more like bond than
these Bond films I want a badass villain
I want a cool story I want it to be
suspenseful I want to be surprised and I
want to get a little more of bonds story
like his backstory and stuff
I don't want I don't want to like
[ __ ] to overload me I want just a
little bit and I feel like it's gonna
deliver I mean they proved they could do
it with Skyfall and if it's not better
than Skyfall I don't think that means
it's a bad movie you know so let's let's
just wait and see anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can uh hey guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe today and feel
like a reject come a real reject today
subscribe and don't just feel right feel
Ryan right this is tough this is tough I
don't know what to call my fanbase
Chuck Norris hates you one this student
has been begging for a shout-out on the
comment boxes now I don't know how many
times like I say there's a [ __ ] text
right here that says follow the link in
the description box to earn a shout-out
now you keep harassing me in the comment
boxes but if you wanted a shout-out
oh yeah [ __ ] go here you know what
and if you did put it a long time ago
that means you missed the shot ah you
have to watch every [ __ ] video you
know that what do you think I do this
Chuck Norris why do you think I do it
it's a hook you know
I say request a shout out and whoever
requests a shout out now they're forced
to watch every video views I wonder
Chuck Norris hates me